i'm going to go next to uh to beth rigby
of sky news
thank you prime minister just just to
follow up on robert's question
on july the 17th your exact words were
that you should be able to review
outstanding restrictions and allow a
more significant
return to normality from november at the
earliest
possibly in time for christmas can i
just be clear are you now saying
that without that mass testing regime
coming off between then and now
people watching this should accept that
they're going to have smaller gatherings
of family at christmas and they're not
going to be able to have
a big party that perhaps they would have
been hoping for
and professor wis woody just to ask you
when i asked you a while back about your
biggest regret at the beginning of this
pandemic
you talked about the importance of mass
testing
now the director of testing sarah j
marsh has apologized to people
unable to get a test because of lab
processing issues being at her
words a critical pinch point how
worried are you that the testing system
is already under strain
before we've even hit the winter
okay i'll hand over to patrick a second
but beth
look thanks for that i i think the
honest answer is it is just too early to
say
um we've got two big
uh projects that were we're backing the
first is
the change in public behavior that we
hope to see through the announcements
that we're
making today through the uh through the
rule of six for
uh the the plan to drive down uh the
current
uh increase uh by changing our behavior
back again to by
adhering to uh the rule of six very
strictly that
we hope will uh will work uh we're also
hoping as i
as i said uh that the moonshot approach
will will work and that we'll be able to
deliver
a mass testing uh lateral flow type mass
testing
that will give people the the the
freedom past the less they pass
the the knowledge that uh they are not
infectious and can
uh can uh hang out with other people who
are not infectious in a in a
in a sort of pre-covered way now that's
that's a very ambitious plan
but we're working on it uh very very
hard and very fast as
as you can imagine both those were
backing both those horses
and uh were were were backing them flat
out
but the thing we need now the thing we
need now is for
uh everybody to work together to enforce
the rule of six and
and and get the current spike uh get the
current spike down but
obviously we'll keep the public informed
uh about all the progress we're making
sorry forgive me chris um
when we started off the first wave of
this in
in the uk we had low thousands of tests
a day
and that really constrained what we
could do and that was
very difficult made it very difficult
for us to do proper planning
i think what you saw at the beginning of
this presentation depressing
though in many ways it is is we are now
in a much better place we do actually
now have a much greater understanding in
considerable detail
as to what is going on and we're able to
uh provide testing across the system
that's the glass half full glass half
empty is
clearly at any point there are more
things we could do if we had more
testing
now the biggest gains are near the
beginning because you're moving into
being able to test people who've got
symptoms uh healthcare workers whether
outbreaks and so on
but there are still constraints and
that's one of the reasons it's important
as with
very very many other things in the nhs
this is no different that it's
critical that those who do need to be
tested in particular people with
symptoms or ones where people of
uh situations where people have been
told to for a variety of reasons
social care working for example uh get
tested
but it is also important that people who
really don't have a clear clinical
indication
currently don't because we do still have
constraints and i think that's what
this is this is demonstrating if we get
more testing
every significant uplift of testing we
get
we can do more things and one of the
things that i
hear quite often when i hear kind of
debates in the public is people will say
well can't you test for this and can't
you test that the answer is
well let's get the testing capacity
first and then work out what we're going
to do with it and at any given level of
capacity
you can do more things that actually
open up more parts of the system and
the prime minister gave a an idea about
what you could do if you had a really
large
uh in a sense huge change in testing uh
if the technology was there to do that
so
i think you know we we have to be uh
honest with ourselves
that we're in a much better place than
we were but there are still constraints
and those constraints are not just
magically going to disappear
and the demand on testing has increased
uh outpacing at certain points our
increase in testing and that may happen
for a little while i think